Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today Bobbie Azarian, who is a cognitive
neuroscientist, blogger for Psychology Today and
also writer of The Substory Road to Omega. Bobby,
it's great to have you back on today.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me,
David. Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So maybe to start with,
you know, many of us have been seeing I mean, we
can go back and talk about during the pandemic.
We can talk about January 6th in many different
ways and from different people. We've been seeing
behavior that seems dysregulated at minimum
and other words that we could apply to
it at at worse if we want to. Can you talk
first from a neuroscience standpoint? What
is it that is happening when people's the way?
I would as a layman say it, their common sense
seems to be almost hijacked in a sense, and
they behave in ways that many of us find
hard to imagine ever behaving ourselves.
What is it that's taking place?
Speaker 4: So I guess the first thing I'd say is
that if we don't look at what's going on through
the lens of science, in particular psychology
and more specifically a theory called terror
management theory, we're going to be completely
lost about what's going on. Things will just seem
completely random and chaotic and unpredictable.
And in a sense, they are certainly chaotic,
but they're not totally unpredictable. So if
we're looking at things from the perspective
of psychology and we look at all of the events
that have transpired since really the emergence
of Trump, really you can go back farther than
that. Then we see that a lot of these responses
were due to events that call cause existential
fear in people. So, for example, Trump the
emergence of Trump himself was a response to fears
over ISIS and fears over immigration when Trump
took power. Then, for people on the left,
their fear was having an incompetent leader
that Stokes division in the pandemic hit.
And there's like it's the biggest form of
existential fear. We're all freaked out. So
when you have those conditions, basically
that fear creates certain psychological
effects that promote tribalism, that make us
more aggressive towards people who don't share
our world view. And once that process happens,
it's very hard to reverse that because there are
certain psychological phenomena like something I
can talk about in a minute called amygdala hijack,
where basically we're controlled by our fears.
We're sort of programed rather than being these
rational thinkers. And once this happens, one side
becoming more extreme, polarized, the
other side that's trying to balance that.
And then you get on this trajectory where you're
going towards just more divisive state. And
so if you don't do something to get a hold of
that, basically we're headed towards disaster.
Speaker 1: So let's think a little bit like,
for example, when I hear you say that a lot of
this can be triggered when we're around people
that don't share our world view and it creates
creates this Luban cycle with something like the
anti vaccine, anti mass protests. I'm not seeing
the pro vaccine and pro mask people behave the
same way as the anti, although in some general
sense maybe it would happen because both are
being challenged in terms of their worldview.
The anti mask people are being challenged by
the pro and the pro by the anti. But we're
seeing the erratic behavior almost exclusively
from the anti vaccine and anti mask people. So
what's causing that difference, that split?
Speaker 4: Yes. So I guess I would say
that when you're talking about a very specific
topic relating to the mass, then you do see that
behavior on the right. That doesn't make sense
to us as progressives, but it can do things that
so so the left will be more like gung ho
about wearing masks and taking precautions. So
I not that it's not that extreme behavior
is always bad. Extremism is bad when the
ideas are extremely stupid. So you can have
radical good ideas that can transform society.
And when you have a situation where there's this
looming existential threat like the pandemic,
it can catalyze civil rights movements or it can
catalyze civil wars. And really, when the threat
is so extreme, it kind of does both those things
at the same time. So going back to what you said,
I would argue that it's not fully on the right
and in the left. It manifests itself in different
ways, for example. Yeah. So, for example, you have
the Black Lives Matter movement, and that really
exploded after the George Floyd murder. And that
was in May, just right at the beginning of the
pandemic, when in us we started seeing these like
warnings to wear masks, not go outside and stuff
like that. And that explosion that protests like
nationwide protests occurred because everyone was
so fearful because of the pandemic. And then you
had this like countermovement. You had people like
saying blue lives matter in response to
Black Lives Matter and. That was problematic,
didn't even make sense because the whole point
of Black Lives Matter was saying black lives
should matter as much as everyone else's life.
So it was it was really all lives matter from
the beginning. It's very ironic that, like the
other side started saying, all lives matter when,
like, that was what the first movement was
about. Anyway, you get this defund the police
movement in response to like this right wing blue
lives matter, all lives matter thing. And like
that slogan like is very extreme. And now I
see political campaign ads using that slogan
to scare people away from Democrats. So I
would say that the left matches the right.
They just do it in completely different ways.
Speaker 1: Right. And that's interesting. You
bring up the defund now being used against some
on the left. From the beginning, I said I don't
think this is a productive slogan and here's why.
And it's very interesting that you point to that.
I do want to get you mentioned the amygdala
hijack. Can you talk about what that is?
So we're all on the same page with it.
Speaker 4: Yeah. So basically, when we go
through life, we're kind of mostly on autopilot.
And some studies have show that the famous LIBET
studies on free will basically we're programed and
we have a certain set of beliefs and goals and we
kind of behave according to those. But a lot of
times our programed behavior won't be optimal.
So if we're fearful, we might get aggressive. When
that happens, there's another part of the brain
that is responsible for kicking in and producing
rational behavior where we analyze the situation
and then we make decisions where we're like
more in control than being controlled by our
instincts and reflexes. So the two brain areas
that are important are the amygdala and the
prefrontal cortex. The amygdala is involved in
processing threat and it is associated with the
fear response. So when we do perceive a threat,
basically it triggers the amygdala and in that
puts us in sort of like a fight or flight mode.
And then the prefrontal cortex, which is a newer
part of the brain evolutionarily, evolutionarily.
And that part is supposed to calm the amygdala.
And the problem is, in times where fear is
superhigh, the prefrontal cortex can't do its
job because the amygdala is just constantly being
triggered. There's also some interesting studies
that show correlations between impaired prefrontal
cortex function, which is responsible for this.
We call it cognitive control or executive
control regulating regulating your emotions.
And so we see impaired executive control
with people who are religious fundamentalists
or we see it with people who score high on
surveys of racism. We see it in people with
drug addiction. So basically those people are less
in control. You could say they have less free will
because they're unable to override this programing
and this effect that you have when basically
the amygdala hijacks the cognitive system. So what
we can do about that is become aware of that and
simply becoming aware, having what's called meta
awareness can give you control over that. And then
there are exercises you can do, like practicing
mindfulness to kind of strengthen the prefrontal
cortex because it really is like a muscle.
Speaker 1: Thinking of that, I ask this not
to excuse me morally, ethically or legally the
actions of the January 6th rioters, but I ask
it in order to try to understand, is it a type
of situation where you're in this mass of people
and someone decides to start busting down
doors or breaking windows and going in?
Is it possible that you sort of experience an
amygdala hijack there and you just kind of are
riding high and carried in and participating,
not because you went intending to do that,
but because the situation around
you sort of puts you into that
state? Is that a situation where this happens?
Speaker 4: Definitely, and I would like to say
that it's really important to understand these
people, because we don't understand the mindset
we'll have will be completely lost in terms of
how to get through to them. So when you talk about
empathy for these people, it's not so much about,
like wanting to be a better human being, to have
empathy, empathy for them. It's really more
about being practical, finding a solution to
the problem. So these people, just like you
said during like the capital attack, they're
tuned in to social media. They're plugged in to
the people who are stoking that fear constantly.
They're responding to the others around them
and things that are happening in real time.
And so you kind of get this collective
effect where it's like. The amygdala
hijack is kind of like spreading from
person to person. And once that happens,
if there's not someone that comes out and says,
hey, everybody like this is kind of crazy,
right? It's just going to snowball.
Speaker 1: Is is mob mentality kind
of a layman's term for group amygdala hijack?
Speaker 4: Yes, definitely, it's related to that,
it's also related to tribalism. I didn't go into
terror management theory. I know we talked about
it last time. I could talk about that a little
bit in relation to, like, this mob mentality.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would be interested in hearing
that because, I mean, what we're you know,
many of us are starting to say, is this going
to happen again? How likely are these folks
who in some online spaces are saying, if we don't
get X, it's going to be time for January six, part
two or whatever? I think it would be important to
understand what it is that could could get them
there, but also what could prevent a.
Speaker 4:
Yeah, absolutely, so I think to prevent it,
I think to get an understanding of what's
actually going on, we have to understand terror
management theory. So terror management theory
starts with the fear of death. So at some point
in the evolutionary development of man or human,
I should say, we became intelligent enough
to be aware of our own mortality, that
someday we're going to inevitably die and be
gone and possibly forgotten. And that realization
can be paralyzing if you don't have a
psychological mechanism for coping with that.
So when that happened, that necessitated
the invention of cultural worldviews like
religions, political ideologies, national
identities, cultural worldviews basically
act as death anxiety buffer's by giving
us a sense of purpose and meaning in life.
Actually, they are said to offer
paths to immortality. So a religion
excuse me, religion offers a path to literal
immortality through the concept of an afterlife.
And national identities offer a path to what's
called symbolic immortality through feeling
like you're part of this bigger movement, this
bigger idea that will outlive the individual.
So what terror management theory says is that
if cultural worldviews are how we deal with
existential fear, then in times when there's some
existential threat looming or we're reminded of
our death for some other reason, we are going to
cling to our cultural worldviews more. We're going
to become more tribal and we're going to become
more aggressive towards people who have different
worldviews. So really, it explains tribalism. It's
interesting because world is basically you needed
some sort of worldview to emerge to have human
civilization, because it's what binds people
together under a common idea. But at the same
time, if you have people at different parts of
the world, different cultural worldviews are going
to emerge. So the thing that unites people within
the group is the very same thing that can that
divides people into tribes. So one of the ways
to deal with this is to look at your different
world views, look at what you have in common,
like, for example, look at the things that the
right are complaining about and they're fearful
about that are valid. Now, there are going to be
a lot of things that are valid, a lot of crazy
things that just have nothing to do with reality.
But there are going to be some things that are
legitimate concerns, things that they care about.
And we try to align interests at that point.
And if we can do that, we can start to create
some sort of unifying worldview and we really
need to do that consciously. It doesn't happen
by accident. So there will be a second capital
attack, something not necessarily have capital,
but something that's like that. Right. We're
headed there. And if we don't do something
very consciously to change that trajectory,
I would predict that it will happen for sure.
Speaker 1: So would I. So would I. We've been
speaking with Bobby Azarian, who's a cognitive
neuroscientist, blogger for Psychology Today, and
also writes The Substance Road to Omega. Bobby,
it's always great having you on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Great. David, can I mention the road
to a megaproject? Yes, that's that's really
what me and some colleagues and friends and
allies have started to design, which sets out a
solution for all of this. So everything we talked
about, problem of tribalism, understanding that
a Bayesian reasoning system, a logical
reason, reasoning system to fight
misinformation and conspiracy theories. And that
plan is up that road to a mega subsect dotcom.